we're told to graph this system of
equations and identify the number of
solutions that it has so they have the
system of equations here so they want us
to graph each of these equations and
think a little bit about the solutions
so the first equation here I'll rewrite
it so I'll graph it in the same color
that I write it this first equation it's
already in slope-intercept form Y is
equal to 3x plus 1 we see that the slope
or M is equal to 3 and we see that the y
intercept the y intercept here is equal
to 1 so let me be clear that is also the
slope I just called it M because a lot
of times people say Y is equal to MX
plus B so we can graph it we can look at
its y-intercept the point 0 1 must be on
this graph so that's the point 0 the
point 0 1 right there this is the y-axis
that is the x-axis and the slope is 3
that means if we move one in the
positive x direction we're going to move
up 3 in the positive y direction so we
move one in the X direction we move up 3
if we moved 2 in the X direction we
would move up 6 we would move up 6 just
like that because 6 over 2 is still 3
likewise if we moved down 1 if we went
negative 1 and X we would go negative 3
and Y so negative 1 negative 3 because
negative 3 divided by negative 1 is
still 3 if we went negative 2 in X we
would go negative 6 1 2 3 4 5 6 in Y so
these are all points along the line and
I can connect the dots now so let me do
that so let me connect the dots as best
as I can this should be a line not a
curve I don't have some my hand is 100%
steady but I think you get let me do it
a little bit better than that I think I
can do a better job than that let me
draw that's even worse
all right last attempt I'm just throwing
me off
so last attempt right here the last
attempt right here there you go so
that's that first line right there Y is
equal to 3x plus 1 so let me do the
second one now so it's written in
standard form right now 2y plus 4 is
equal to 6x we want to get this in
slope-intercept form y is equal to MX
plus B so a good place to start
could be to subtract this 4 from both
sides that goes on the other side so
let's subtract 4 from both sides of this
equation the left-hand side we're left
with just a 2y and then the right-hand
side becomes 6x minus 4 so 2y is equal
to 6x minus 4 and then to get everything
in terms to solve for y we just have to
divide everything by 2 so let's divide
everything by 2 and we get Y is equal to
3x minus 2y is equal to 3x minus 2 so
that's the second equation in
slope-intercept form so same drill here
the y-intercept is negative 2 so we go
that's negative 1 negative 2 right there
and it's slope is 3 and notice it's
slope is the same as the other line so
it's going to have the same inclination
if we move one in the x direction we
move up in up three in the Y direction 1
up 3 we go up 1 up 3 just like that if
we go back 1 and X we go down 3 back 1
and X we go down 3 just like that so if
we connect the dots here it'll look
something like this do my best to draw a
straight line so the second graph 2y
plus 4 equals 6 we put it into slope
intercept form and we graphed it now the
whole point of this question was to
identify the number of solutions that it
has this system a solution to a system
of equations is an x and y value that
satisfy both of these equations now if
there were such an x and y value that
satisfy both of these equations then
that x and y value would have to lie on
both of these graphs because this blue
line is all of the pairs of x and y's
that satisfy the first equation the red
line is all of the pairs of X's and Y's
that satisfy the second equation so if
something is going to satisfy both it's
got to be on both lines when you look
here are there any points that are on
both lines well no these these two lines
never intersect a point of intersection
is a point that is common
to both of these lines know if they
don't intersect no intersection
intersection so there is not a solution
to this system equation so there is
there is no solution we know that we
know that because these two lines don't
intersect and it will you didn't even
have to graph it the the kind of
giveaway was that these are two
different lines they have different
y-intercepts
but their slopes are identical so if you
have two different y-intercepts and your
slopes are identical then you have two
different lines that will never
intersect and if they represent a system
or if their the graphs of the system of
equations that system has no solution